okay so the topic of this presentation
today is cellular respiration you might
know that cellular respiration is a
process performed by the mitochondria in
order to create a molecule called ATP
adenosine triphosphate and that's what
you see pictured here well let's go
ahead and get started so when we look at
adenosine triphosphate you're often hear
it called the energy molecule of the
cell an analogy that you might also hear
is it's kind of like the cells money or
currency you know the more money you
have the more goods and services you can
purchase well you can look at it in this
sense the more ATP that the mitochondria
produces the more work can be done and
here's a list of reasons why ATP is
needed ATP is required in the movement
you know you might be taking these notes
right now well energy is causing your
muscles to move across your paper in a
very coordinated manner I hope so you
can read legibly your handwriting the
ability to reproduce requires ATP you
might know that sperm cells male sperm
cells swim through the female
reproductive system and that swimming
process requires the use of energy in
order for proteins to be created protein
synthesis requires the use of ATP so
this is just a small list of reasons why
the cell needs to make ATP so first of
all it's called ATP adenosine
triphosphate you can see I've just
highlighted the three phosphates in this
molecule here and around each phosphorus
is are the oxygens there and so you can
see there are three of them in this
picture
and during the hydrolysis of ATP if you
recall hydrolysis is where you take the
addition of water a large molecule with
the addition of water and various
enzymes can be broken down into smaller
molecules so ATP with the addition of
water can be broken down into adp and a
single phosphate that
releases energy usually in the form of
heat now if you're wondering in my notes
why does it say p with a lowercase I why
is there a subscript I you might often
see that that's just a reminder that
phosphates are in organic inorganic
means they do not contain carbon if you
look in the picture look at the
phosphates in the picture there's no
carbon phosphates are inorganic and so
when we look at this simplistic diagram
here of an ATP molecule water plus
various enzymes during the process of
hydrolysis the hydrolysis of ATP water
plus various enzymes will cause that
third phosphate to be broken off and in
that process heat energy is typically
released and so it's this heat this
energy that's released which drives
cellular processes heat often activates
enzymes which start chemical reactions
so when we look at cellular respiration
here is the chemical formula for
cellular respiration in the picture here
you have an electron microscope picture
of a mitochondria I've heard students
often compare this to kind of a
footprint on the moon it's a pretty good
analogy and so here's the mitochondria
and the mitochondria performs the
process called cellular respiration and
so cellular respiration primarily occurs
in the mitochondria I say primarily
because there's this early step known as
glycolysis which takes place in the
cytoplasm of the cell
so in this artist drawing we can see
that inside of the mitochondria there's
a inner layer that twists back and forth
it's kind of colored an orangish color
and filled air filling that inner orange
layer is kind of a blue fluid like you
see in this picture this is called the
matrix that's going to be important as
we go through the process so cellular
respiration begins with a molecule of
glucose the glucose which you obtained
from the foods that you eat so energy
from the glucose
that we eat is converted into you might
know into 36 to 38 ATP molecules
depending on the condition certain
environmental conditions will cause 36
ATP's to be made certain environmental
conditions can cause 38 ATP's to be made
but one thing I want to mention is that
cellular respiration is very much
necessary for both autotrophs and
heterotrophs you know there's a myth out
there that because plants are the only
ones that have chloroplasts then that
means animals must be the only ones that
have mitochondria and that's a myth
that's not true all eukaryotes all
eukaryotes have mitochondria eukaryotes
include fungus Protista plants and
animals so mitochondria are essential in
both heterotrophs and autotrophs plants
and animals and fungus and Protista to
be exact
okay as we now get into the process
let's first examine what's called
glycolysis glycolysis begins in the
cytoplasm of a cell and it begins with a
molecule of glucose you know in my
picture I've shown glucose as the blue
ring of circles notice how there are six
carbons in that ring because there are
six carbons and glucose
there's also 12 hydrogen's and six
oxygens you know for simplicity I've
only drawn the glucose as the six
carbons just keep in mind there's still
12 hydrogen's and six oxygens so
glycolysis begins with the addition of
two ATP molecules now this might seem
counterproductive at first after all the
purpose is to make ATP so why is ATP
being spent well the analogy I like to
make is in business you have to spend a
little bit of money in business to make
a lot more of money for instance you
might have a wonderful invention that
you think is gonna make you very rich
but if nobody knows about the invention
no one's gonna buy it so you spend maybe
a few thousand dollars on advertising
radio ads and television ads
Internet ads you basically market the
product spent a few thousand dollars and
then to attract customers who will
hopefully buy your product to make you
millions of dollars in that case it's
smart to spend a few thousand dollars in
order to make a few million well in the
production of ATP in order to make 36 to
38 ATP's which is what we're gonna have
at the end of this process two ATP's are
needed to start this process so here's
two ATP molecules and with the help of
various enzymes ATP is brought over to
the glucose and with the help of various
enzymes the ATP is broken heat is
released
notice how the phosphate was left behind
well there's a second ATP molecule there
and again enzymes bring the second ATP
molecule over to the glucose break apart
the ATP heat is released the releasing
of the heat causes that glucose molecule
to break into two fragments call of
molecules that we now call
phosphoglyceraldehyde notice how fast
more glyceraldehydes
are three carbon molecules you might
often hear me call them P gal P gal is
just an abbreviation for phosphor
glyceraldehyde well what happens next is
again various enzymes there's all kinds
of enzymes in the cytoplasm of the cell
various enzymes add a couple more
phosphates to the pee gals that changes
them a little bit they're not called pee
gals anymore and as the process
continues a molecule by the name or by
the abbreviation of nad nad stands for a
molecule called nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide I'm just going to call it
nad watch what nad does nad acts like a
taxi for hydrogen nad will pick up a
hydrogen and deliver the hydrogen to the
mitochondria if you missed it here comes
another one another nad will pick up a
hydrogen and carry it away to the
mitochondria that NADH that was carried
away that any
is gonna be very important when we get
to later parts of cellular respiration
near the end of glycolysis ATP is now
also created and so an ADP with the help
of various enzymes will strip off one of
the phosphates another ADP with help of
various enzymes will strip off a second
phosphate another ADP with the help of
various enzymes will strip off the third
phosphate and yet another ADP with the
help of enzymes will strip off the
fourth phosphate What's Left Behind are
two three carbon molecules that we call
pyruvates there's the formula right
there for pyruvates notice how there are
only three carbons to them those
pyruvates are not waste they have a role
to play in the next step of glycolic
scuse me they have a role to play in the
next step of cellular respiration but
before we go into the next step of
cellular respiration let's just take a
look at what's been created to pyruvate
molecules which they're not waste those
pyruvates have a role to play still a
total of four ATP molecules have been
created you might often hear it called a
net gain of two ATP's well that's
because two ATP's were needed at the
start to produce four so when you take
into consideration the two that were
used at the beginning to make a total of
four that's often what we mean by a net
gain of two ATP molecules and then
notice the NADH molecules were created
as well those nadh --is that moved into
the mitochondria i like to call them a
hydrogen taxi because they're delivering
hydrogen from point A the cytoplasm
point to point B the mitochondria kind
of like a taxi delivers people from
point A to point B let's move on so now
when we take a look at our cell we're
gonna move to the powerhouse those two
pyruvates are going to enter the
mitochondria so now what we need to do
is we need to zoom out into the
mitochondria and take a closer look when
we zoom on into the mitochondria we
see the two pyruvates inside of the
mitochondria there's a there's a layer
in the mitochondria that twists and
folds back and forth that layer you
might often hear is called the cristae
and inside of that layer inside of the
cristae is a fluid called the matrix and
so the pyruvates are in that matrix area
in the inner layer of the mitochondria
so when we now move on into cellular
respiration we're gonna begin with the
process called the Krebs cycle you know
if if you notice from the animation
again the krebs cycle takes place in the
matrix if you're in my biology class
there's a textbook diagram that's broken
into various stages and so when I say
step one I'm also referring to the
diagram in your textbook so step one the
pyruvates are broken into acetic acid
well you can see the two pyruvates right
there we're gonna follow the blue
pyruvate on top the same thing happens
to the one on the bottom but for
simplicity we're just gonna follow the
one on the top so what happens is in
order for the pyruvate to be broken into
acetic acid a few things need to happen
first nad comes and strips away a
hydrogen and carries the hydrogen over
to another area of the matrix those
hydrogen's are going to be really
important when we get to the final step
for cellular respiration so in the
process of the pyruvate being broken
into acetic acid carbon dioxide waste is
also generated there are enzymes that
cause these barns to break and one of
the carbon drifts away with two oxygens
in the form of carbon dioxide that
leaves behind acetic acid the three
carbon pyruvate was broken into a two
carbon acetic acid one of the carbons
exited as carbon dioxide
well now what happens with the acetic
acid
so what happens next we're looking at
area two of the diagram from your book a
big molecule by the name of coenzyme a
is gonna bond to that acetic acid and
when the acetic acid and the coenzyme a
bond together you just kind of mush the
two words together it goes by a new name
of acetyl co a you can see acetyl co a
is a really big molecule because the co
a the the coenzyme a is a really big
molecule well what happens is this
acetyl co a is a fairly short-lived
molecule it doesn't last very long
you'll see what happens in just a moment
when we move on into area number 3 of
our diagram citric acid is formed with
citric acid is formed when a four carbon
molecule from the previous round of the
krebs cycle keep in mind the krebs cycle
is a continuous process so from the
previous krebs cycle a four carbon
molecule is created that four carbon
molecule bonds with the acetyl co a
enzymes break off that coenzyme a part
and that's the big part when enzymes
break off that coenzyme a what's left
behind is a six carbon molecule by the
name of citric acid so what we're seeing
is we're seeing the molecules change as
a result of various enzymes when we move
on into area four of the diagram from
our textbook what we're gonna see is
that six carbon molecule by the name of
citric acid is broken down into a five
carbon molecule well in order for that
to happen there are of course various
enzymes but also a molecule of nad comes
and strips away a hydrogen the hydrogen
accumulates again in another area of the
matrix we're gonna see why that's
important in a few moments but the
citric acid which is a six carbon
molecule is broken into a five carbon
molecule as a result of nad stripping
the hydrogen as a result of enzymes and
also one of the carbons is turned into
carbon dioxide citric acid is a six
carbon molecule but one of the carbons
turns into carbon dioxide and enzymes
break it away and it floats away and it
exits as waste so now there's only a
five carbon molecule left over well what
happens next now we move on to area five
of the diagram that five carbon molecule
with the help of various enzymes is
going to be broken down into a four
carbon molecule and just like last time
one of the one of the products that's
created is NADH a molecule of nad will
come in strip a hydrogen away the
hydrogen accumulates with all of the
other hydrogen's in an in another area
of the matrix we're gonna see why that's
important in just a moment another thing
that happens is a molecule of ATP is
created so an adp and a phosphate are
brought together with the help of
various enzymes and that helps to bind
ADP and P together to make a molecule of
ATP so another molecule of ATP is
created now keep in mind there are my
notes say that two ATP's were made even
though I just showed one because we're
following the blue carbons on top the
same thing happens to the blue carbons
on the bottom just for simplicity we're
only focusing on the blue carbons on top
but another ATP molecule would have been
created in the blue carbons in the
bottom of the picture as well so that's
why my notes say two ATP's are created
one ATP from the top of the blue carbons
on top one ATP from the blue carbons on
the bottom and notice how my notes say a
five carbon molecule is broken into a
four carbon well where'd the extra
carbon go just like the last couple
times it's released as carbon dioxide
waste enzymes break off one of the
carbons into in the form of carbon
dioxide and it's released as a waste
molecule well now we move on the area 6
of the diagram from our textbook and it
says enzymes rearrange that for carbon
from one four carbon molecule into
another four carbon molecule watch the
animation three two one
enzymes rearrange the four carbon
molecule from one four carbon molecule
to another in the process of doing this
a couple more hydrogen taxis are created
a molecule of nad comes in and strips
away a hydrogen delivers the hydrogen to
another area in the matrix we'll see why
that's important and another molecule by
the name of FA D very similar to nad FA
D comes and strips away not one but two
hydrogen's that's why it's called fadh2
all these hydrogen's are accumulating in
another area of the matrix because
they're going to be used in the final
part of cellular respiration and so as
we finish up and keep in mind that this
is a cycle in order for this to be a
cycle it needs to restart so that four
carbon molecule is gonna bond with an
acetyl co a we saw a sudoko a a moment
ago the co a will be released and what's
left behind a citric acid now we've
restarted the krebs cycle that's why
it's called a cycle because it's a
continual process and so the process
simply repeats itself now if we do a
quick summary if we do a quick summary
of the Krebs cycle you can see that only
two molecules of ATP are created but the
the main prize from the Krebs cycle is
all the creation of nadh and fadh2 those
are gonna be hugely important during the
final step of cellular respiration
called the electron transport chain
let's finish that up right now
so as we look at our mitochondria again
what we're about to do is we're about to
zoom in deeper into the mitochondria and
what we're gonna look at is the matrix
the boundary the inner membrane
separating the matrix which is the light
orange from the outer layer which is the
dark orange let's zoom out in alright
and when we zoom out in we can
see that embedded in the inner membrane
is a protein channel and enzyme by the
name of ATP synthase now if you've
already learned about photosynthesis
you've seen this enzyme ATP synthase
before so it's going to be really
important as we go through the next step
so if you are in my biology class again
look at the picture the picture from
your textbook has numbered areas so if
we look at area one nadh and fadh2 are
delivered and again their hydrogen is
delivered the nadh and the fadh2 from
the krebs cycle and some nadh from
glycolysis so nadh from glycolysis or
from the krebs cycle is it delivered
we'll watch what happens 3 2 1
when the NADH delivers the hydrogen the
electron from the hydrogen is pulled to
the inner membrane the the proton of the
hydrogen the H+ ion is in the matrix and
this process happens repeatedly NADH
drops off a hydrogen and the hydrogen's
electron goes to the inner membrane and
the H+ ion is in the matrix and again we
have another nadh dropping off at the
electron to the inner membrane and the
hydrogen ion to the matrix and let's not
forget fadh2 so here comes FA da ch2
delivering two hydrogen's and two
electrons so what happens next in area 2
of the diagram an area 2 of the diagram
those hydrogen ions in the matrix the
hydrogen ions at the bottom are going to
be pumped out of the matrix and what
we're setting up or what's being set up
is a steep concentration gradient in the
top of the diagram outside of the matrix
a large amount of hydrogen is at the top
of the diagram a very steep
concentration gradient is being
established that's going to be really
important
when we move on into area 3 when the
concentration gradient reaches a certain
level ATP synthase is activated what
happens is a hydrogen will pass through
the ATP synthase ATP ATP synthase is an
enzyme and what ATP synthase does is it
draws an ADP and a P together allowing
them to bond to make a molecule of ATP
and this process happens 32 to 34 times
now I only show it I think three times
in this animation so a hydrogen diffuses
through the ATP synthase that draws an
ADP and a P together to create ATP then
the process happens again another
hydrogen is drawn through another ADP
and P are brought together to make ATP
now again this can happen 32 to 34 times
depending on the conditions now one of
the problems that's happening is as more
and more and more hydrogen passes
through ATP synthase the concentration
gradient lessens the two sides of a
membrane are getting closer to
equilibrium and that's no good there has
to be the Steep concentration gradient
needs to be maintained or ATP synthase
stops working so something has to come
and pick up and remove those hydrogen's
that are in the matrix and that will
summarize area four of our diagram
oxygen is going to pick up two of the
hydrogen's that have already passed
through ATP synthase and a couple of
electrons from the inner membrane to
create a molecule of water the water
simply exits as waste and as more water
exits taking more hydrogen the steepness
of the concentration gradient is
reestablished now again in my biology
class you are hopefully preparing
yourself for this essay question so I'll
talk to you about this essay question
during class and so there you go if
you're in my
biology class you know pause the video
and try to put these steps in order from
start to finish if you're in my class
I'd love to see you before or after
school if you want me to help you check
your answers so pause the video and good
luck